Electric cars, they're nothing new.
Porsche has been wired since way back.
This was 100 percent electric 100 years before that was cool.
But this? Yeah, this is new.
It's called the Taycan, Porsche's first fully electric sports car.
Big step? Nah, more of a giant leap.
It charges fast, feels fast, goes fast and you still drive it like a Porsche.
Kids, luggage, friends you like, friends you don't like,...
Taycan can handle it all.
Want to go hundreds of miles on a charge?
Get in.
In the Taycan, the kilowatt is king.
Plug in, charge up, text your mom, scroll the feed, boom, done.
Rear-wheel drive, all-wheel drive, sedan or wagon, any color you want.
Match your eyes, match your dog's eyes, match my eyes.
It's silent, smooth, powerful.
It's everything Porsche has learned from the road, from the tracks, from the family.
See what I'm saying?
Same Porsche, different energy.